Hello and bienvenido to Cusco.
This is one of the most beautiful cities in all of South America,...
...and not only is it the gateway to Machu Picchu,...
...but it was once the capital of the ancient Incan Empire...
...and there is a lot of beautiful things to see and do here.
The history and cultures of both the Inca and colonial Spanish are both present in Cusco...
...and part of what makes the city so vibrant and fascinating.
In Cusco, you'll find extraordinary textiles,...
...archaeological wonders and lively gatherings.
This market is definitely one of my favorite places in all of Cusco.
It's full of color and it's just an explosion for the senses.
This is Qorikancha, the sun temple,...
...and it was the most important temple for the Incan religion,...
...and if you can imagine, it used to be completely covered in gold.
This beautiful, brightly colored bustling market town is called Pisac...
...and this is where you come when you want to find traditional Peruvian handicrafts.
Check this out my friends,...
...one of the most recognizable ancient ruins in all of the world: Machu Picchu.
The ancient mythical site of Machu Picchu built in the clouds of the Andes Mountains...
...is a bucket list site for almost anyone who travels.